yeah Eric Martha it's a kind of mini
science so by running Muslim I think we
be captivating our life and a scientist
my name is Spencer
I'm the president of the University of
Oslo we are going to have the morning
running truthfully the Nobel laureate
Yamanaka
it's painful in the course but after
that pain you can expect something good
science can be quite hard from time to
time you have success but between each
success you have left to struggle that's
really an important part of designs you
need the support from the supervisors
and from the university it's very long
we need to run like four hours often
it's very painful but after that we can
finish it and we can feel a compressible
science it just takes a bit longer to it
as years but after that pain it's very
rewarding